nous nous réunissons à un moment de
grand péril pour le monde les mots du
Secrétaire général de l'ONU Anthony Obut
Pérez le 77e assemblée générale des
Nations unies s'ouvrent aujourd'hui à
New York en présence de 150 chefs
d'états de gouvernement conflits et
catastrophes climatiques méfiants et
division pauvreté inégalités
discrimination le contexte est
particulièrement alarmant est-ce que
quelqu'un se rend compte dans quel dans
quel monde on vit
franchement ça me fait péter des plombs
sont fermées
les universités
pour tes gosses
le chauffage tu le baisses ta gueule tu
la fermes enfin c'est trop
c'est une sorte de carte météo celle de
l'électricité avec le dispositif ecow
what pas de problème aujourd'hui la
carte est verte cet hiver attention à la
surconsommation elle pourrait devenir
orange et même rouge dans ce cas des
consommateurs volontaires se réprié de
débrancher leurs appareils électriques
pour éviter les coupures Isabelle Lamy
ont fait partie
[Musique]
[Rires]
elle s'est inscrite sur le site Mon
ecowatt.fr en cas d'alerte elle recevra
un texto ou un mail l'appelant des
éco-gestes comme éteindre ses appareils
ménagers sans problème le micro-ondes
sans problème le four
et la machine à laver elle est même
prête à éteindre ses lumières et à
acheter cette torche regardez on y voit
comment plein jour je suis complètement
perdu là moi je qu'on me dise quoi faire
là je vais comme un mouton je vais faire
exactement ce qu'on me dit et puis voilà
et puis voilà parce que j'y arrive pas
parce que je sais pas j'ai pas les
réponses je peux les réponses qu'on me
dise mon ordinateur il met genre je
prends un coup de jus si j'achète plus
de billets d'avion par an voilà
j'ai deux billets d'avion par an voilà
qu'on me dise voilà c'est que ce soit
clinique là qu'on mette des coups de
fouet à chaque fois et puis je vais tout
respecter parce que là moi je suis perdu
vrai ou faux après chaque prime de
Secret Story Benjamin Castaldi
souhaitait rentrer chez lui
exclusivement en hélicoptère
c'était pas tous les jours oui mais
c'est vrai bah bien sûr c'était une fois
par semaine
et puis de toute façon comme en plus
Hidalgo a fait que c'était payant et que
j'arrive pas à voir la carte de
résidence elle veut pas me la filer de
toute façon je vais être obligé de le
vendre et je vais prendre un scooter
électrique voilà comme j'ai les moyens
Chelsea d'ailleurs j'annonce là je vends
mon scooter parce qu'on veut pas me
donner la carte de résidence
parce que j'en ai déjà une pour la
bagnole que j'utilise très peu
d'ailleurs mais je peux pas la garer
parce qu'à l'enlever toutes les places
de parking donc je sais même plus la
mettre à bagnole donc je peux je peux
plus donc je voulais juste rentrer une
fois par semaine à la campagne pour vous
pouvoir coucher mon petit et la seule
façon de le faire c'est d'être pendant
un hélicoptère à après l'émission donc
du jeudi je crois et donc je vais et mes
Champigné la moitié il paye la moitié ça
coûtait combien ça devait être 4000
euros de l'heure un truc comme ça il y
avait combien d'heures une heure et
demie 1h30 donc ça va coûter 6000 €
cette affaire et le pilote dans mes chez
moi parce que je repartais dans le
pilote dormez chez toi en plus et une
bonne nouvelle ce mardi matin la baleine
de 15 tonnes qui s'était échoué sur une
plage du Finistère a réussi à retrouver
le large les volontaires ont tout fait
pour la déloger du sable elle était
complètement bloquée ils ont creusé des
tranchées utilisaient des tractopelles
et l'animal a réussi à repartir à la
marée haute c'est un miracle pour l'ONG
sipard dans les Vosges un homme et
poursuivi pour avoir fait l'amour à des
poules bon il faudrait peut-être
prévenir les copains de l'Est que ça
veut pas vraiment dire ça une poule
partie
c'est ce que j'attendais que je ne
retrouve pas mais le bouillon et ben le
bouillon il sent la moule et moi j'adore
la moule c'est vraiment très très très
très très bon
le gravlax j'adore non mais séries
attention Namasté tout de suite
l'auteur des faits âgés d'une
soixantaine d'années a expliqué qu'il a
toujours procédé avec tendresse
l'histoire ne dit pas s'il rencontrait
ses partenaires via l'appli tinder
je l'aime d'amour
calmez-vous le patron m'a juste envoyé
comme ça sans aucune entre parenthèse
formation même si je suis capable de le
faire mais
j'étais entre parenthèses avec ma ma
[ __ ] et mon couteau quoi d'accord ce qui
pour un seul à bord de chaude est
toujours
c'est lourd c'est l'éléphant
[Applaudissements]
et sinon c'est désormais qui est dans la
mascotte des Blackburn Rover en foot un
indice ils sont au moins deux et ça
c'est dur à digérer
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]